time to get industrial big robots like
this are in factories everywhere but
it's not safe to have people around them
because they're so powerful this robot
can swing a car around she is incredibly
brave getting this close to it this is a
little scary I mean that's a big
dangerous robot she's playing with there
yes it is scary so we ventured to San
Francisco to meet gutsy Madelyn and her
gigantic machine these machines are
currently blind to their environments so
I think if we want to take these out of
factories and bring them in to live
environments like film sets or
construction sites or laboratories they
need to have some awareness of the
random objects that are moving through
its space one side there's the rational
me who is like yeah this is a dangerous
machine it's just a machine I can't
really let my guard down on the other
side as I go how this is cool looking
and it's responding to me and it gets me
this robot really looks kind of sentient
the way it moves around and looks at her
it really looks like it's alive it's
hard not to prescribe a personality onto
this machine we call her ABBA and she's
my dancing queen
yeah but can it do the robot dance
great moves Tom how does Madelyn get up
close and personal with ABBA
without sending an SOS Madelyn has given
this robot eyes using a motion capture
system a series of 10 high-resolution
motion capture cameras are positioned
all around the workspace meaning the
robot can see as much as possible in
order for the robot to track Madelyn she
wears retro-reflective motion capture
dots which the motion capture cameras
can track her at a rate of 519 frames
per second this is a standard motion
capture marker what you'll see is it has
three dots made out of retro reflective
material that means that whatever light
hits it it bounced directly back this
can accurately reconstruct her 3d
real-world position to within one
millimeter
or for one hundredth of an inch the
robot also has sensors built into its
arm so it knows exactly where it is
this combined with knowing where
Madeline is allows the robot to either
follow mere or avoid them by developing
technology like this Madeline is hoping
that one day humans and robots like
these can work safely alongside each
other it's very cool to work with these
machines but it they are like a wild
creature in some ways it's also a big
orange thing so it reminds me of a tiger
it's a it's a metal tiger for giving us
some industrial size science Madeline
you're a super trouper